okay when did you
like obviously we turn 18 we're adults
yeah yeah what did you feel like you
became an adult
uh still waiting yeah oh really okay
okay I it's it's like when do you feel
like that you felt that you were
comfortable in like who you were as a
person and as an adult and like I would
say
26. I'm still alive
so uncomfortable I'm still uncomfortable
with those things because one thing I I
there was this feeling that I always
struggled to to shake and I don't know
where this comes from but you know when
you like let's say maybe maybe this is
because I I went straight into youtubing
after finishing University we only turn
up to a place and because we we're like
we're like we're like YouTubers and
stuff and I don't know what it is but
like you feel that like everyone is like
doing their job yeah and you feel like
you are like fake at being there yeah
being like present like you feel that
everyone knows their role and you feel
like you're faking that you're involved
in this every time I get invited to like
a company outing or like a fancy dinner
party and [__] I'm just like I am a
child I should not I make YouTube videos
I should not be yeah even though all the
adults around you are just like yeah
he's gonna he's got a job he's making
money he's got his own business he's an
entrepreneur but like in your mind
you're just like no I'm not I'm just a
[__] kid making dumb videos on the
internet and somehow making a living
like I don't feel like all of you actual
professional adults yeah whatever that
means I think I think my one of the
biggest realizations I had when I was
like fully an adult was uh yeah growing
up I thought the one thing that would
happen when I went into the Working
World was I'd realized that people would
suddenly become competent and then I
soon realized that in no matter which
industry no matter where you are uh
there will always be incompetent people
and they'll especially somehow be
incompetent people in higher uh
positions of high power yeah like no
matter what and I it would I I just had
this image that I was like in [__]
University I'm just like dealing with
this University kids I'll just be like
everyone here's a [__] idiot when I
get into the Working World people only
start to make sense the World's Gonna
Make Sense people will do their jobs and
then I went into the Working World and
people still didn't do anything and
you're like damn adults are dumb
adult adults are [__] dumbass is this
about being an adult is like just
realizing that the world is actually
incompetent and everyone's coping with
the fact like damn did you live like
this holy [__] I'm like how are you
adulting how the [__] do you do these
companies function and then somehow
these companies do function but you go
into the companies at like a you know
either an entry level you see how the
company functions internally and you're
like how is this how how does the world
turn I don't understand when there are
this many incompetent people in the
world maybe this is just a me thing it's
people like that that make me realize
like oh you can be a dumb ass adult and
still survive yeah yeah well I I think
yeah because you're you remember that
one guy who [__] everything up more
than the 10 guys who did their job yeah
yeah exactly is it here already yeah wow
like I thought that one guy who does
nothing in a group project was like a
school thing you know I I I I know I
thought that one guy who sits around and
does nothing and takes all the credit
for the group project was a school thing
and then I realized that this is just a
world that's called a CEO
it's people like that who end up in high
positions of power it's like yes I am
present you just hope right you hope
that those people don't get rewarded for
that and then people who work hard do
and yeah that's kind of the trust you
have in the systems yeah who work hard
you just hope they'll be Reckoning and
you know like and it's interesting right
because it's like that one kid in every
school project that as you were saying
like [__] it just shows up but takes
all the credit yeah you know some of
those people just never grow out of it
and they're just like oh I mean it
worked in school it probably works as an
adult let's see how it goes yeah and
then there are some people I feel uh who
are in that position during school and
they're just like wait this works in a
school environment right if I did that
[__] in the real world I'm getting
sacked like I'll be out of a job oh if
you're not in Japan if you're not in
Japan in Japan they're just like we've
gained the system yeah just show up and
don't do anything and you
okay I don't know if this is a loaded
question but do you guys feel like
adults I already asked that
[Music]
okay so to reiterate on that question
though what would you say is the
defining feature of what you consider an
adult I think
like what is the difference between an
adult and a still a [__] like uh
young guy I think that being an adult
means feeling like you have a place in
the world and you have a purpose and if
you're serving a goal whether it's
yourself or working in a company and you
feel that you're in something that is is
right for you and you're you're
benefiting yourself or whatever it is
I think it's like when to yourself it
feels that way right I think Society is
it the term adult yeah 18 but I think
the moment you internalize like when you
feel that like you yourself have like
figured it not figured it out but like
you feel that okay I've I'm starting to
get a a grasp on this life thing yeah
because when you're like the the pieces
start to fall in place right yeah
because like I think what you just said
all right we'll do we'll do that later
um like I I feel like what you just
described is pretty much like the almost
like the opposite for me because when I
feel like an adult uh when I when I
first started to feel like an adult is
when I first started to feel like lost
and I kind of realized holy [__]
everyone my age feels lost you because
when you think that you found like we're
as an adult you're striving to find that
place where you kind of feel like you
know your place in the world you're
bringing something useful I know so many
[__] people let's say like I think
most people don't feel that yeah most
people most people don't feel that way
most people like that I've met in like
the mid to early 20s to like sometimes
late 30s early 40s they feel [__]
lost and they're like I do not know what
I am contributing yeah uh and I do not
know where my place and you think that
feeling of being lost equates to being
an adult the shared experience yeah of
that loss being lost yeah I feel like
because when when you are a teenager you
think that you're just gonna suddenly
figure it out and I remember getting
like I remember getting my first like
getting my first acceptance letter for
like my first real job which you all
know what it is I thought [__] yeah I I
thought maybe she mentioned I thought to
myself [__] this is it I am finally an
adult I've made it man I've got my first
job actually gonna have disposable
income gonna get a paycheck worked there
for a year and I felt more lost than
when I started and I feel like that
experience is probably not going to be
an alien experience for a lot of people
and then when I started feeling more
comfortable was when I talked to people
and I was like oh this isn't a me thing
this is an everyone thing we're all
feeling the same way we all have no
[__] clue see but then like I would
argue you know you said that like during
you know like high school or whatever
there's a lot of people who are just
like yeah I have like a set plan I'm
gonna figure that [__] out but I don't
know me personally I feel lost as [__]
during high school because I was just
kind of like I I understood that in this
school environment is the norm though
yeah but that's the thing right it's
like so it's interesting you say that
the feeling of being lost made you feel
like an adult because I feel like when I
was lost it made me feel like I was
still a child because I was still trying
to figure out my place in society and
then it's when I finally figured out
what I wanted to do which was this whole
YouTube creative thing
um that's when I started to be like okay
this isn't like games there's just games
and play anymore like this is like a
serious
occupation this is a serious job for me
now yeah and like even though I still
you know treat that whole business and
occupation as you know with a lot of fun
and you know uh casual you know way I
also understand that the back of my mind
I'm like if I [__] this up then it's not
just a matter of like oh well no I've
lost a hobby or I've lost a thing that I
like like I have lost a job like I am
you know and that creates serious
consequences in my life so I feel like
for me it was the opposite being in the
middle is consequences I think I think
yeah yeah because in high school if you
[__] up you had people around you
there to support you right whether it
you know and you know obviously not
every high school kid has this
particular very three different
interpretations yeah yeah I mean I
because I feel like I think they'll have
valid things as well yeah yeah
absolutely I think they just come from
our own subjective life experience
because I feel like we are all in very
lucky positions now
um and that we do have a job which we
find fulfilling you know that is a
[__] Rarity and that is a goal that
everyone strives to get and I feel so
[__] blessed every day I wake up and
I know that I'm doing something that I
find fulfilling because doing like three
four years of an unfulfilling job uh
working for a company is that's soul
sucking and people have done that for
far longer than I had to experience so
you know it's it's something I think we
have to acknowledge that
I you know I feel like we've found our
purpose in life absolutely a lot earlier
than some other people may have found
yet isn't it interesting that even
though we you know as far as what we've
talked about of the definition of being
an adult Yeah by definition since we
have found a job that is an actual
legitimate job and we find satisfaction
and we feel fulfilled it which is what
we have kind of lightly defined as being
an adult yeah yet if you ask any
traditional media about YouTubers
they'll be like oh these [__] kids
just [__] around I don't know
and it's like it's it's interesting like
this this disparity of like having a a
stable job I guess or like you know a
real world job that's not like you know
content creation on YouTube is it
considered like the adult choice and yet
I'm sure there's a lot of people in
those like job fields who maybe don't
feel that way themselves yeah I mean
like I feel like times change a lot and
you just got to adapt with the times of
being like [__] 40 years ago you were
you was looked like a degenerate child
if you're still living with your parents
uh at the age of like 30 or 28 and now
with like the reality of the world is
that the housing then rent prices are so
[__] high give me money and I'll [__]
get the [__] out like that there are a
lot of people who still live with their
parents not because they are a deadbeat
degenerate Financial Choice it's a wise
Financial Choice and they still have a
job that they commute to yeah from like
with their parents and it's just like a
smart thing to do nowadays you know what
I'm saying it's just like the way the
world is
but like what I okay so you're an adult
when you feel like an adult I feel at
the end of the day yeah because I you
know I guess what I was trying to get is
like how do you like what is the turning
point or what is that the series of
thoughts or emotions that make you feel
that way because obviously of course you
feel like an adult when you're an adult
whatever yeah but like how what is the
what what is that okay at least for me
personally it's the feeling of every
action I take from here on out every
choice I make from here on out have real
life consequences whether that be good
or bad I think I think the term you're
looking for is responsibility yes
that's it I am responsible for
everything I do everything I say who I
interact with how I interact with
everything in my world is now directly
going to come back to me there's no
parent buffer there's no teacher buffer
there's no anyone in between to like
hold your hands I always wanted that
though as a kid yeah I hated the fact
that I was tied to like
my you know not not in a bad way but
like tied everything was directly tied
to my parents in some way I always
wanted to have Independence well and I
think that's why a lot of high school
kids you know have that feeling of like
I want to be an adult yeah yeah but one
of The Independents so I'm American
do you do you ever like you know you
know you like as a kid the kind of like
stereotype is there are kids who grow up
way too fast and they miss like their
let's say childhood or things that you
can only experience as a kid do you feel
like
do you feel like they're a parts of your
childhood that you do miss or as a kid
were you just like I just want to be an
adult as fast as possible uh and it's
kind of like let's say met the hype of
everything that you thought being an
adult as a kid I mean I think I think
there's a lot of again we have to which
bear in mind that I think it's different
right because I think that again like
you said we're very we're success
someone we do so obviously
being successful at whatever age or you
know having money at 23 is obviously
like great whatever I'm like that's
awesome that's so much better than being
23 and having to work two jobs just to
pay rent yeah that's like and I think
that's not on the person from their
childhood I think that's just purely of
like
boy you dealt a good hand in life where
you [__] did you make any big mistakes
that came back to haunt you like I guess
there's a bunch of reasons so it's hard
to like be like I I think it's it's
impossible to be like predetermined if
you were going to be someone who like
thought that your childhood was better
yeah I think it's something that just
happens this [__] up happens like what
if you uh you know you you had a you was
you had a really good childhood but you
were super you couldn't wait to be an
adult you matured whatever and maybe you
got like a bad car crash and then maybe
you can't you lost you know maybe you're
blind or maybe like something bad
happened to you or maybe a loved one
died it's like okay well that would
completely change how you view all of
this stuff following and you would
obviously look back at your childhood in
a lot more like kind of uh what's the
word uh Nostalgia yeah uh because you're
like oh everything was fun and safe and
great back then I could play video games
and drink ribena and it was fun like
yeah I guess we can only really talk
about our personal yeah I mean we can
only talk about our personal experiences
however I do think that uh I if I had to
go back I'd probably still be enjoy
being a kid because all I always play
video games and that's kind of what I
want to do now okay question what age if
you could go back in time to your
childhood right for let's say a week to
experience it again how old would you be
do being like 15 16 was like the best
age I love that because I felt old
enough to enjoy [__] and be mature about
it yeah I hated the exams obviously yeah
but I felt like I was caught like I was
I was mature enough but I could still
spend all day playing video games I I
would go back to like 12. 12 or 12. I
think 12. because because at like 12 is
like kind of that point where you're
like you know transitioning from primary
school or Elementary School to high
school at least in Australia right and I
feel like just you're taking more
serious a little bit more seriously than
while you're in elementary school but
you still have all of the benefits of
being out fresh out of elementary school
right like you can you can do like more
like kind of childlike activities and
like be okay with it you know you can
you can basically indulge in all your
hobbies right whether they're like more
mature or less mature for your age like
you know I could I could do all of like
the more immature I guess like high
school Hobbies at the same time but I if
but if I wanted to [__] stay at home
and you know watch anime for 15 hours
while you know sucking on my thumb then
I can also do that too like it's fine
like you get you're like take me back to
and I like that yeah
pay me back take me back to the time
where I could watch anything and I'd
probably enjoy it
as a jaded old man now I can't do that
anymore take me back to when I
discovered one piece and like yeah like
I [__] Marathon that [__] exactly as
an adult you just miss being able to not
feel bad about spending one week doing
[__] nothing yeah and now because
that was your whole life yeah so the
next time we had to do that is when we
retire yeah we're like 50 or 60 years
old and old man but we don't have the we
don't have as much energy as we did back
then so you're kind of limited to what
you can watch a lot of TV yeah you can
do that but I mean like to me I think I
can just boil it down like a sentence
which is like when was the last
Christmas I was actually excited about
you know
when I got that Nintendo Wii it was a
game changer yeah yeah and to me it was
like I think it was around like 12 13
years old that was like the last point
where I'm like oh I can actually get
presents it was when holidays actually
like mid-some right right it wasn't just
like I'm doing stuff with my family and
friends it was like a [__] event yeah
yeah it was nice it was nice in here too
you Christmas Day you're like damn I
gotta play Crash Bandicoot Spyro and
this new again I don't know which one to
do first
it was just the excitement of just being
like this is just gonna be a banger day
yeah the next week I am in heaven I'm
gonna play new video games that I can
only get this many video games at once
on this day I'm gonna eat some bang of
food yeah and uh it's just gonna be a
good day and that's that to me is kind
of like the pure happiness that I will
never experience again as an adult
because it's a different kind of it's
it's a different kind of Happiness which
you know it's we we I'm still I'm very
happy being an adult but you know there
is a certain type of happiness you feel
as a kid that I would love to experience
again just just once just
just and I feel the only way to like
realistically be able to experience that
again is when you have your own kids
where you can kind of live vicarious
seriously through the through the
enjoyment of watching your kids
experience that exact same thing that
you probably experienced as a kid as
well become an anime fan yeah until yeah
and then the moment when my son or
daughter comes after me and they go
what's one piece now if you like rest in
peace
that's Paul